obviously a very sad moment yeah it is
very sad I remember seeing him about six
months before he left and talking about
this another crazy adventure of his and
and looking forward very much the
stories he tells he came back because
he's he's nothing if not an extremely
funny man
and and to I know many of his friends
will be missing those stories now he was
trying to emulate the Shackleton
expedition which of course was the rate
failure didn't make it so presumably he
knew there must be considerable risk to
what he was doing
yes he's I mean his military record is
one that speaks of understanding risk
and he knew what he was doing I don't
think anybody can have appreciated quite
the dangers and and to die in such a way
in such a place is really very
heartbreaking particularly is he had
just been evacuated was was in a
hospital and chilly and we had that that
final broadcast from him when he he
talked about that summit being just out
of reach now heartbreaking me poignant
to listen to particularly for those who
knew him yes I mean I think that's
absolutely right he's he's a man who has
never backed away from a challenge
and when I met him in Afghanistan it was
a as many your listeners will male
viewers will know military relationships
are often very short but very intense
and we worked together for a number of
months in those early days before the
main British forces arrived in Helmand
and he's just not somebody who ever
backs away from a challenge oh he wasn't
somebody who ever backed away from a
challenge and his ability to get on with
people was just extraordinary
so to imagine him walking alone across
the Antarctic was a feat of huge courage
not just in the physical element which I
think we can all recognize but also in
the human element as he who's the man
who I mean remarkable strength of mind
that that would have taken that complete
solitude for 471 days as well as the
physical endurance yeah I mean there's
genuinely here's one of the most
impressive people I've ever met and and
he's an extraordinary loss and not just
the army from whom he retired not that
long ago but to our country I mean he
really has demonstrated that in it the
days of adventure and heroism are not
dead and our fellow citizens are really
doing the most extraordinary things
still he was raising money for charity I
think more than hundred thousand pounds
was his original target and he's passed
that at the same time what is the point
I mean isn't it isn't this a waste I
mean it's not like serving in
Afghanistan or something like that
though I hear what you're saying and of
course it's not the same but no it's not
a waste I mean I think I think you've
got to look at the spirit of adventure
that he embodied and encapsulated as as
part of a theme for striving for what is
always better always further that is
part of the human need and whether that
be through scientific discovery in our
universities or whether that be through
adventure in these ways what he's what
he's doing is he's part of that human
experience of reaching for the stars and
you know as we've got scientists in this
country who are now you know literally
in the stars with major Tim Peake you
know he's demonstrating that our country
is still very much part of that spirit
of adventure that we launched in many
ways in the 15th and 16th say well sorry
16th and 17th centuries and that that
opportunity to reach for what is greater
than ourselves is what makes us that
much more human even when you do it in a
sense artificially I mean you do have
the option of having food drops when you
try and cross the Antarctic but he
decided he wasn't going to do that he
was gonna drag his sledge with him you
do but but demonstrating the strength of
the human spirit as well as as well as
the human body
he's about pushing it that much further
and there are many things that one could
accuse Henry of but selfishness is not
one it really isn't he consistently gave
more of himself than I think I've seen
other people give in you know in years
and he was trying to complete the
unfinished journey of Shackleton but
there was also a financial aim a
financial legacy that he wanted to for
some that I will it and indeed
tragically he's gone better towards
achieving it in the last few hours as I
I looked at the
website only a little while ago forgive
me if I may plug it in oh please it's on
Virgin Money is hosting it and it's the
Shackleton Solo appeal and he's now here
to 130 something thousand and I very
much hope and it's a sad legacy but I
very much hope that he will he will do
significantly better than that difficult
question but what sort of man was he to
you he was incredibly disrespectful
incredibly funny brilliant soldier I
mean really brilliant soldier really his
men loved him I mean absolutely adored
him and hugely personally courageous I
mean I'm when I met him in Afghanistan
he was pretty much on his own do you
remember when we were in Afghanistan
that the first major British point was
about 3000 forces what you may not know
is before the troops arrived there was a
platoon of Gurkhas and Henry that's it
and Henry was going around to places
largely escorted interacting with people
getting cricket kits out there playing
cricket with but I mean just the most
extraordinary weeks and few months later
Henry carried it off through simple
force of personality I mean the man was
a force of nature and had just loved by
many I'm doing thank you very much thank
you